avec nous dans simon professeur au
département de management de
l'université laval pour parler de la
stratégie de bombardier bonsoir yan
cimon
bonsoir alors comment on doit lire
aujourd'hui la mise à jour la mise en
garde l'avertissement de bombardiers
c'est clairement des résultats qui sont
un peu décevant pour le moins mais il
faut le voir dans le contexte d'une
entreprise qui est en train de se
transformer et qui tenterait aussi
d'essayer de justement mieux gérer son
endettement
donc si on recadre les résultats dans
une perspective de plus long terme c'est
pas nécessairement catastrophique c'est
le signe qu'un virage est en train de se
produire mais il les prochains
trimestres seront déterminants mais on a
l'impression que ça s'éternise cette
transformation cette restructuration
devait arriver bientôt au terme du
virage de bombardier oui tout à fait on
a vu que bombardier a cédé beaucoup
d'éléments d'actif bon pensez simplement
à certaines activités de querétaro qui
sont maintenant cédées à latécoère mais
il ya quand même des bonnes nouvelles on
l'a vu récemment bombardier transport
qui a gagné un contrat important en
chine justement sur les trains à haute
vitesse
donc il ya quand même des bonnes
nouvelles à l'horizon mais il reste que
la restructuration en cours est
importante chez bombardier est
malheureusement comme il ya beaucoup de
retard et de glissements opérationnelle
sera en effet sur les flux financiers
parce qu'évidemment les paiements des
clients n'arrivent pas au moment prévu
puisque les livraisons ne se feront pas
au moment prévu et donc il ya des
retards dans secteur ferroviaire des
retards des retraits de wagons également
certains endroits on pense aux aussi
beaucoup au royaume uni en suisse on dit
que des caricatures aussi qu'ils
caricaturent bombardier pour ces retards
ce a des répercussions sur la
rentabilité de l'entreprise
les répercussions sont d'abord et avant
tout réputationnel parce que bombardier
souhaite rester une entreprise qui est
reconnu comme un leader mondial à la
fois en aviation mais aussi du côté du
matériel roulant mais les répercussions
sont bons financière on l'a dit parce
que malheureusement les nouvelles
qui sont pas très bons en suisse ont un
impact sur les activités sur l'opinion
d'éventuels acheteurs ont un impact
financier parce que justement le côté
opérationnel n'est peut-être un peu trop
ambitieux en termes de date de livraison
ce qui a fait qu'il ya eu des
glissements des problèmes liés à
certains fournisseurs stratégiques aussi
y ont entraîné des délais qui dit délai
dit bien évidemment de l'argent qu'ils
n'entrent pas dans les coffres de
bombardier mais dit aussi coûts parce
qu'évidemment beaucoup de ces contrats
prévoient des pénalités pénalité qui
doivent être négociées comme dans le cas
des pénalités prévues avec les chemins
de fer fédéraux suisses par exemple
bombardier laisse planer aussi le doute
sur sa participation dans airbus canada
et le projet à 220 est ce que bombardier
n'a plus les moyens d'investir dans la
220 est ce que c'est ça qu'on comprend
bombardier n'est actuellement
probablement pas en position de faire
une infusion importante pour la
pérennisation du programme
le message lancé aujourd'hui et sans
doute déjà une manière d'envoyer d'abord
un message au grand public pour
conscientiser le grand public sur ces
enjeux là mais aussi une manière de
commencer une d'une certaine façon une
discussion beaucoup plus public avec
airbus
on se souviendra que airbus bombardier
dans leur coentreprise s'était donné le
droit mutuellement de racheter l'autre
avec un horizon déterminant déterminé
pardon bon dans le cas d'airbus par
exemple d'ici 2026 airbus aurait droit
d'une littéralement racheter la partie
de bombardier mais il reste que
bombardier souhaite sans doute voir un
échelonnement de ce rachat
ce qui serait plutôt intéressant du côté
financier pour elle est aussi ça
diminuerait beaucoup de pression sur ses
liquidités et donc tranquillement pas
vite bombardier se retirait dévaluerait
eux aussi sont son investissement dans
la 220 ça c'est l'autre élément à
bombardier annoncé qu'elle réfléchissait
à la valeur de son investissement donc
une dévaluation de l'investissement peut
vouloir dire plusieurs choses mais
certainement que les perspectives de
croissance de cet investissement là du
point de vue bombardier dans sa
situation actuelle ne sont peut-être pas
celle qu'il espérait mais au delà de ça
c'est peut-être aussi une stratégie de
dévaluer maintenant pour être en mesure
après
de pouvoir compter sur des résultats une
croissance plus intéressantes sur un
horizon d'ici 2026 l'entreprise
aura-t-elle les capacités de redresser
sa situation financière selon vous
jusqu'ici bombardier fait les bonnes
choses c'est à dire qu'on vend des
éléments d'actif on essaie d'épurer les
opérations on a fait certains
changements du côté managériales
on a renforcé l'équipe stratégie qui est
de vente du côté aviation donc il ya des
choses intéressantes qui se passe
maintenant faut voir le rythme auquel
ces changements là pour devenir plus
agiles ont font aller plus loin que ce
qu'on nous a présentés comme
restructuration ces derniers trimestres
on aura la suite le 13 février à
l'occasion des résultats financiers en
ciment merci beaucoup pour cette analyse
ce soir ça m'a fait plaisir bonne soirée